well the one hand clearly the idea that
folks can't make money by helping other
people make money is crazy all right
that's the the whole system revolves
around rewards for a job well done so
executive bonuses as a concept we should
not stamp on however to give bonuses to
people who in fact just the opposite and
did so by you know taking advantage of
the loophole in the system and in so
doing I hurt the system dramatically as
equally as crazy so you know I think
that we have every right to be outraged
over some of the bonuses that have been
highlighted and brought to light and
after the Lamar Lynch stuff and AIG on
the other hand I imagine that there are
a percentage perhaps a good percentage
of those people within that group that
deserve those bonuses but there's Rob
ibly also a percentage of people in
there that deserve not only no bonus but
probably get fired and again it's really
hard to come in from you know as a
congressional committee or as the White
House although I thought the White House
had a sensible reaction to this at the
end of the day and try to make that
determination from outside the company